so the clowns over at FoxNews are just
absolutely thrilled that we live in a
country where people are free to work
multiple jobs because one job doesn't
give them a stable standard of living
there's this concept called freedom from
versus freedom to that exists in
political philosophy and it relates the
positive and negative freedoms okay so
positive Liberty is the freedom to do
something and negative Liberty is the
freedom from being stopped by other
people from doing something so the point
is there's different types of Liberty
and sometimes the freedom to do
something is actually only relevant
because there's a lack of freedom
somewhere else so here's an example if I
say it's great to have the freedom in
the United States to work for whichever
company gives you the best health
insurance a counterpoint would be hold
on a second it's terrible to lack the
freedom in the United States to be able
to just work whatever job is the most
rewarding job without being constrained
by worrying about losing your health
insurance that's the way I would see it
okay this gets us to Fox News now if I
said to you if you look at the numbers
of people in the United States who are
working multiple jobs is that a form of
freedom to work as many jobs as you want
or is that actually a reflection of the
lack of freedom that stagnant wages and
a lack of living wages place on people
and force them into having to work
multiple jobs
I consider the working multiple jobs
thing an indicator of the lack of
freedom that too many workers in the
United States experience which gets us
to the Fox News perspective on this
issue where absolute and total farcical
clowns Pete hagseth and Ainsley Earhardt
are just gushing they're literally
thanking God about how wonderful it is
that we live in a country where people
can work multiple jobs and it's it's
mind-blowing that this is actually an
analysis that resonates with millions of
people in this country take a look you
know you know what Connell Harris says
is so it's so disingenuous for most of
my life I've worked two or three or four
types of jobs of sources of income today
you can do that more flexibly how many
people do you know
who do something and then maybe in their
free time they drive an uber or they do
something else to bring an extra cash
thank God we live in the kind of country
where we have the innovation and
flexibility where you can bring in money
from different things when I'm in an
uber and you talk to them you get to
know on many of them do say they're
doing this to make a little extra money
and we start talking about how much
extra do you mind if I ask do you make a
week and it's it's enough to pay for
their kids to take an extra swim class
this one guy told me or it's enough to
put a little bit of money aside for
their kids to go to college I love those
types of people my dad worked several
jobs if you had the opportunity make a
little extra he would these people are
truly sick I mean it's it's not
inspiring that so many people have to
work second jobs and third jobs it would
be inspiring to live in a country where
people didn't have to do that right this
is like those supposedly heartwarming
inspirational stories about how great
Americans are because when Little Jimmy
needed a prosthetic leg because of a
medical condition Jimmy's classmates and
teachers came together to fundraise and
do bake sales to raise money what a
great country
no no it's disgusting that one of the
richest countries in the world makes the
reality one where Jimmy couldn't just
get the prosthetic leg and needed money
from his classmates and from teachers
and from the parents of classmates
buying muffins at a bake sale it's
backwards okay and I actually want to go
further this multiple job status quo
that's so common actually reinforces the
system we have I've talked about this in
my segments about types of activism that
go beyond just signing a petition or
calling your elected official I've said
before corporations have huge
disproportionate control over our
systems the legal system the judicial
system media everything they maintain
control in part by making sure that
there's a system in which the average
person doesn't go protest doesn't demand
change doesn't participate in strategic
defaults or mass rallies in urban
centers and one of the best ways to make
sure people don't do that that people
don't protest and people don't demand
change is if they can't even miss a day
of work
because that would be two or three jobs
that they might get fired from or they
can't miss a day of work because they
can't buy food if they miss that day of
work that's a really great way to make
sure people don't show up and actually
protest and demand real change and if
you're in a situation where you even
need multiple jobs then you are very
unlikely to have the wherewithal and
resources to go in protest and demand
changes to the system that caused you to
need two or three jobs in the first
place this is a self-reinforcing
feedback loop and I mean listen I don't
know the Fox News hosts who said it's
just so inspiring to live in a country
thank God we live in a country where
people can work ten jobs if that's what
they want to do they may be useful
idiots they may be actual cogs in the
wheel deliberately reinforcing the
system it doesn't really matter okay the
effect is that they are reinforcing the
system that big corporations have
already done a pretty damn good job at
reinforcing really disturbing and
disgusting stuff